10h de concert exceptionnel demain
dimanche à la cour neuve exceptionnel à
deux titres la qualité de laffiche et
les intentions de ce concert puisque
cette recette sa recette ira à
l'Éthiopie il est intitulé chanteur sans
frontières comme le disque du même nom
Nicole cornulanglois et Yve breux ont
assister aux toutes dernières
répétitions cette foisci il
s'agit du
FR 150000 personnes attendu à 120 francs
l'entrée oui c'est du fr de l'Afrique du
or Afrique
Afrique et
naturellement Éthiopie Soudan Mali Sael
et cetera l'Afrique
sans le truc c'est un problème mécanique
quand je parle de l'Afrique Afrique
l'Afrique sans frque c'est un jeu de mot
malheureusement ce jeu de mot là c'est
des choses qui existent mais en dehors
de ça VO de ça que les artistes
retrouvent c'est la première fois que
les Français les Africains jouent sur la
même scène pour une cause c'est
intéressant je qu' seront sensible pour
ça ici mais ils seront également en
Afrique les chanteurs du disque pour
l'Éthiopie vendu à 24 millions
d'exemplaes et des nouveaux des trios
des duos des
solos
C Pierre Bachelet avec 80 chanteurs dont
de pardieu Coluche Balavoine Matias ALID
Renault bien sûr et le petit dernier
marque
lavoineelle lesux
rol seront dans le cœur final qui sera
entendu à 3 km à la ronde des moyens
gigantesques pour la plus fabuleuse
affiche jamais réunie dans notre pays
une question pourtant le contrôle et la
gestion des
recettes c'est comme si les gens vous
disent entre ne rien faire et le faire
le faire même s'il y a entre entreetemps
s'il y a des gens qui qui je sais pas
qui sucr au passage même sur le terrain
là-bas j'en sais rien je dis peut-être
des conneries
complètement il y a toujours quelque
chose qui arrive entre ça et rester les
bras croisés en disant bon on fait rien
je trouve qu'il faut
faire sur la terre
desées Têt en
l'air étranger au vérités premières
énoncé par des cons jamais touché le
fond la
misère et je crie et je pleure et je ris
au pied d'une fleur des champs et égar
et insouciant dans l'âme du printemps
cœur battant cœur serré par la
détresse par les
fa
beauté de la
vie